oh my god I've never blown my nose on
camera
breaking new ground here oh yeah hot one
season 21.
[Music]
hey what's going on everybody for first
week Feast I'm Sean Evans and you're
watching hot ones it's the show with hot
questions and even hotter wings and
today we're joined by Melissa McCarthy
she's an academy award-nominated actor
whose resume includes everything from
beloved TV sitcoms to record shattering
comedies and acclaimed dramatic
performances you can also catch her as
Ursula and Disney's The Little Mermaid
which is set to release in theaters on
May 26th Melissa McCarthy welcome to the
show thank you see you tomorrow
right away no you know what that would
be
record you know
you know had your chance you had your
chance but here you are trapped you're a
hostage on the show now I know how are
you around spicy food before we get
started oh terrible I have no threshold
for spicy at all which would make this
one of my worst uh choices in life and I
make kind of bad choices so this is
saying something
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
I don't get nervous for a lot of things
I am so weirdly nervous
[Music]
that's that's one I
think
okay oh it's getting but it's warming up
yeah a little bit a little bit okay
we're in for one today
[Music]
because now I'm like all right no
actually I think maybe you're just a
natural Melissa we'll see where this
goes but I think you might be in the
future I can see it in your eyes I can
see it in your eyes
so anecdotally The Little Mermaid has to
be top five Disney movie soundtracks of
all time from your perspective what was
the most important thing to nail while
tackling the iconic Poor Unfortunate
Souls number
oh five of her I think there's something
about The Little Mermaid that I feel
like people have ownership in and they
feel like it's their story in so many
different Generations have already kind
of claimed it as their own and you know
Pat Carroll killed it I mean she her
original performance and song is just so
iconic to me and I loved it but it took
a minute because I was was so apparent I
was so scared to sing right like I'm not
a singer so to do that it's like I mean
it's kind of like I mean it felt a
little bit about like I had somehow got
like got put on the Lakers
now you gotta dunk now you gotta read it
I know I have to perform and it was like
well I got through the con but now I
actually have to like wear the shorts
which is
just wearing shorts in general is um not
a great idea
[Music]
Curry they're saying it as if it's like
oh it's gonna be refreshing and fruity
also it's like I'm I'm also eating this
like I've never actually eaten anything
before
okay yeah
this one
yeah it has some sharpness to it I'm
gonna say that's quite a jump from one
I feel like now I'm cross-pollinating I
know I know what do I do oh this one's
the walls closing on you here on hot
ones man I'll make all my things I'm
like I know exactly how I'm gonna do
this
[Music]
how did signing up for acting classes
with Michael Harney change the
trajectory of your career you once told
The Hollywood Reporter I'm quite
positive he's the reason I'm an actor
for sure 100
I picked a random class it was a Meisner
two-year class and Michael Harney just
kind of came in I talk about armor all
the time when I'm I forgot that that's
where I got that from that's from
Michael he would say I I stripped all of
that down you take it all off in here
and he would say but I never ever want
you to ever step out of this door
without putting it back on he's like
because it's you're too open for the
world but in here you can take it all
off
I realize I've stolen my whole thing of
like how I prepare for a part I'm like
is completely from Michael Harney oh
Michael oh I almost burned myself
[Laughter]
we're going to three we're going to
three maybe it's time to put the armor
back on you know for yes I would like
mouth armor right now
[Music]
I don't know what's happening but now
I'm like pretty good
as a member of SNL's five timer Club
what do you think is like the closest
you've ever flown to the sun while
hosting that show live I think the
craziest thing is I did on the 40th
I was doing I was coming onto the news
and it was with Tina Fey and it was I
think Jane Curtin had come back
and uh Amy was on it and then they were
like you come in and I was doing Chris
Farley's down by the river guy and
they'd found his code and they were like
carefully like took it in because
they're like we don't want to alter it
but like so I was wearing it and fully
dressed as Chris I got so nervous like I
can't do what he did and I afraid I
didn't want to make fun of it I didn't
want to do a bad job
on the sweet stage manager as I'm like I
keep like
um the sweet stage manager came up and
he grabbed my legs and he goes honey are
you okay and I've never had this happen
my knees were buckling in a way that my
whole my whole I literally weren't in
control I was holding the door waiting
to go in and I literally I was like this
and first of all really really weird
when you're like I am not physically
controlling my body in any way and I'm
about to go live after somebody that I
like really hold in such high regard
with three icons to me three female
comedians that I like
and I was and he grabbed my legs and I
was like I'm fine fine
and then I was just like steam train I
have to I can't let him down
and then I did it but I I truly was like
I don't know when I get on the other
side of the door if my legs are gonna
work so I mean that was just I was like
I I don't know where I am in the Galaxy
like I've truly felt out of body
[Music]
so this one is the chili lengua de Fuego
oh [__] I don't know a lot going on
oh I don't want I should stretch my
mouth right and this one's kind of
another one of those jumps I think oh
I'm just gonna warning you okay I'll
take the warning
this is I don't think I'm oh yeah
oh
yeah that's a bit of a jump yeah that
hit it hit nothing in the front of my
mouth and then literally it's like I got
a bee sting on my like what is it like
it did my usual I think that's lower
yeah
well on that note let me just ask you an
interview question you know I'm sure so
I loved reading stories about you
growing up because I am a fellow
Illinois native so Plainfield Carbondale
Joliet they just sort of wash over me
nostalgically yes where are you from
again Crystal Lake which is like an hour
and a half north of where you grew up in
Plainfield my memory of Plainfield
actually is now kind of just hitting me
but I had like a pathological fear of
tornadoes because there was like a
catastrophic when I was like three or
four years old that happened yes I was
not three or four years old yeah you
must have been like oh my God
um yeah no there's a good reason to
associate that it's like there's Tornado
Alley which is now exactly where my
parents live which is fun
um I was down in car I was down at SIU
at Carbondale
um here I'll just clear my throat with
this whole milk
nothing really straightens up a throat
like whole milk
um and I came home for the weekend just
to like see my parents and like see some
friends
and I went and I was visiting a friend
who like lived in these townhouses we
were like sitting on the couch in front
of like patio windows I don't remember
what happened but I think it must have
been a pressure change and I just
remember him grabbing me like really
roughly and jerking me by the shirt and
we went towards his basement stairs and
then it just we were like clearly
lightning him because it was such a loud
sound and now I know it's like the
pressure felt weird so we didn't know
what was going on
and we stayed there for you know a few
minutes but then every it was just quiet
again like strangely quiet and we came
out and like that window was blown wow
and he's like something's weird and he
went upstairs and as he got closer to
the top of the stairs he just turned
around and was like there's no the
upstairs is gone
and then we walked outside and he was
the last house on this whole block and
there were groups of two townhouses
together and his was the very last one
and the entire block was gone whoa only
into basements and then it was just his
first floor and the one next to him was
completely gone
and it was just the craziest thing so
you you should be it's not a crazy thing
to be like maybe playing field and
tornadoes aren't friendly
what is this one Los Calientes Rojo here
oh God too much
I got on my laptop right
why don't I feel anything
this is one of those that kind of takes
a second to really find you there
there we go
it's in it oh I know okay I know I know
I understand
oh wow yeah you've got stuff I have I
have my own milk
you're a genius genius at work I'm
stretching I put milk in a bottle but
I'll take it genius at work genius at
work all right Melissa McCarthy we have
a recurring segment on our show called
explain that gram we do a deep dive on
our guest Instagram interesting pictures
that need more context so we'll pull the
picture up over here on the monitor you
just tell us the bigger story okay
oh yeah all right
incredible picture
Factory on rocking track suits to one of
the biggest look at me Red Carpet Events
of the year as Ben and I came in
literally everybody as they caught like
because they caught us they were just
like
and I was like and she's in like and
somebody would be like I'm dying inside
I'm dying in these shoes and I was like
I'm gonna get a drink
and by the way that beautiful woman in
the yellow dress I was in a pharmacy in
La once and she was ironically and she
goes I swear I don't only wear yellow
and I was like okay
he's like
but I didn't I
do laughing glasses on I just thought it
was someone weirdly being like I like
elephants
she's like I don't know I don't always
wear yellow and I was like well
it's the person standing in front of the
picture when you and your husband went
back and she's like can I take a picture
so she was very nice but I was like oh
it's a it's a reunion
weirdly the small of my back just got
hot
will this make my life I feel like
um like maybe my lips will be Fuller
when I'm done you get a little bit of a
free treatment here on hot ones you know
Melissa McCarthy it's the least we can
do this is the uh spicy shark thrown an
eye lift every week
spicy shark guys spicy shark this is
gonna be terrible foreign
[Music]
like spicy smoke yeah so this one
it sort of fills up and you try to
breathe in to live it all it gets worse
it's like a gas that takes up all the
space in the robe I know I know
it's it's escalating right it's gonna
build a little bit it's gonna build a
little bit but don't worry for this
question I got a nice long wind up for
you
there you go hit the hit the spray now
hit the spray the cow
oh
so in a 2018 profile with the New York
Times you said we're in a lot of trouble
if it all becomes cops and capes and
horror and Grim what do you think is
lost when Hollywood stops caring so much
about making audiences laugh
I think we're gonna work I think it's a
world of trouble I think when and I love
all types of movies and films and shows
and books and every time I'll take any
kind of story you've got I just want to
keep Variety in the pie I think once you
go darker darker darker darker darker
and it's only dark gets valued and it's
only the worst of humanity if it's
something where yeah and like oh how did
it end well there's no hope
it's like I want to cry I want to be
heartbroken I want to feel hopeful and I
want to laugh and
somehow the new the new log line is that
comedies don't work
I think bad comedies don't work I think
bad movies don't work but I will fight
to my last breath which will be in about
four more wings
that comedies are important and I think
it brings people together
I think there's something deceptive like
I almost I'm like almost like another
bite
chill
this is a terrible decision
I had to oh yeah
well I think the first side didn't have
it
I know why would I why would I somewhere
Ben's like
because you're being brave Melissa
you're taking it on are your lips on
fire totally okay tongue is numb I'm no
superhero I still feel everything
I'm afraid to mix this with what's going
on in my there you go yeah you almost
pulled that out of nowhere still gas
foreign
[Music]
I don't know
but maybe that's
yeah I'm awaiting a verdict you know
because as you sort of guinea pig test
all these things you know I'm taking
notes over here
I can't tell if it coated it or it's
escalating it might have made things
worse
yeah I'm real unsteady
[Music]
okay so I understand that Guy Fieri
served as inspiration for your character
and bridesmaids when you read this
script what connections did you see
between Megan and the mayor of flavor
town
you know I thought it was something and
I respectfully it's like I thought there
was something about Megan at least in my
head that was someone who's not quite
I just love someone who's maybe not kind
of putting it all together but they're
like is this not [__] amazing but
they're going for it but they're
confident like when confidence is like
in a 50 and self-awareness is low and
self-awareness is low I just remember
saying at one point I was like I think
I'm gonna need a Kanga
and they were like
what and I'm like I think I think if I
get the Kanga I can feel the rest of it
all yeah
my I I would do anything for like just
an ice mouth to kiss oh wait there you
go
oh that's enjoyable actually yeah it
does help uh for like a second yeah it
hurts so much to smile
it really does like I just I I it's okay
so this is me being this is me talking
yeah this is like the hottest sauce in
the world it's crazy
you're terrible at this but would it be
better if I just let you rip it you know
maybe actually maybe maybe
I don't know
[Music]
it neither tastes
right
I know
what to do maybe go with the spray I
don't know oh my God I know oh I can't
even get to the water holy [__]
[Music]
I'm right here with you I'm right here
with you I know I know out of control oh
my God I'm sorry I just did two I just
actually hit a hiccup I know I know oh
my God
I know how I get it I get it I get it I
get it
I'm not sure you have the shittiest job
shop huh you're told me
okay
oh my god I've never blown my nose on
camera
breaking new ground here oh yeah hot one
season 21. yeah
[Music]
I know
I accept it
what gets you fired up when watching
home renovation shows I've heard you
nobody said it helped I don't know
I've heard you compare yourself thank
you so much yeah yeah I've heard you
compare yourself to like a college
football span screaming at the TV when
you don't agree with a design choice
I'm just fully weeping yeah no I good
um
it is I just
this Bread's actually kind of working
for me by the way I don't know who your
bread guy is but clutch oh my God
[Music]
what's your legal situation
oh like
I think exposed obviously you've got to
have lawyers like around the clock I
think it's I'm gonna find out well I'm
waiting for somebody to stress test that
I'm waiting for someone to stress test
that because
in your in your Polo I think I'm exposed
like welcome back to hot ones one time I
was kind of trading notes with Bear
Grylls we seem a little exposed after
after talking to him I'm so sorry I get
it so much Kleenex work
sorry it's you're I'm not in control of
it yeah yeah no it's all good it's all
good no matter what you're going through
on the show way crazier things have
happened was McCarthy you know at the
end of the day
there's got to be some comfort in that
that's like you didn't get picked we
don't like you but you did a good job
you're like I still feel like [__]
man that's the setup this whole Show's a
setup it really is oh my God this is
horrifying
ah
but uh I'm literally having tremors
well it's like the 40th anniversary all
over again
except for the knees
we're all up for body this time
I know I know weird sauce hot sauce but
we are almost gold to be good I mean
should you have to be like like I get
people like spice yeah yeah which I
don't get and it's like a voucher
whoever made it but it's like right I
realize you're like oh you made my
life's work yeah whoever yeah like El
Dorado is like screw you McCarthy but
it's there's a I get what you're I know
what you're saying yeah like I guess
there's something for everyone
so I've been in the habit of asking
movie stars about the most Preposterous
acting exercise that they've ever done
as part of a conservatory program or
acting school as someone who was in the
ground lanes for 10 years like is there
an improv warm-up that you've actually
found is useful for you on like a
Hollywood set like do you use any of
those improv warm-ups for acting
warm-ups I mean the thought of like not
thinking and just having to like say say
what you say what you do or like just
say before you think and don't like you
can't like pre-determine what you're
gonna say because you can only listen to
what the person right before you is
going to say so if you plan it it's
going to be terrible
but I can't say that I've ever been like
you know when I was like working with
somebody great that I was like should we
just stop and lift a disc
I'll pretend as a group lifted imaginary
disc I get it's working together in a
classroom
it's helpful I can't see being like
Javier I'm gonna pretend to live this
and you get on the other side and you
live Christy probably would be like okay
but um
oh my God I can't breathe at all my
whole nose just wiped out
I know how it looks it's that's
Jesus oh this is an application
foreign
God help me is this the one that you're
like
you'll revert you'll die immediately you
know what we're already dead
[Laughter]
yeah okay
I know I know the good news is Melissa
McCarthy this spice soaked Wing flight
it's a distant memory it's behind us
oh wait oh no
I think that I think oh I've avoided it
the whole time and I think I got it oh
but not I not I right not I okay that's
good but no it's still a part of my body
now after watching The Little Mermaid
you know what I couldn't help but to
feel for Ursula you know banish to this
dark corner of the ocean with no one to
hang out with except for her eels after
walking a mile in her tentacles do you
have like a glass half full take on
Ursula like in what ways if at all do
you think she's misunderstood as a
villain I think she oh my God I think
she's totally misunderstood like the
more I always like loved her and I
thought she's
I can't I just need it I need the milk
to be colder
um first time I've ever seen that
incredible
[Music]
oh my God I sound like Ursula
um going back to Michael Harney like
what's her armor and her armor is the
makeup and the hair and the attitude but
it's to kind of cover up for her
loneliness she feels betrayed by her
family and her isolation it's like yes
somebody's bark is really bad but why
are they doing that and they kind of to
kind of play those two sides I thought I
really kind of fell in love
the brighter side of Ursula and look at
you Melissa McCarthy taking on the wings
of death living to tell the tale and now
there's nothing left to do but roll out
the red carpet for you this camera this
camera this camera let the people know
what you have going on in your life
two I'm from Plainfield Illinois
chose to hurt myself with a chicken
wings
um oh I have Little Mermaids coming out
it is so joyful it's such a group of
nice people it's so beautiful and
hopeful it makes us go ahead my mouth
hurts a lot
um I think everything about it it's for
everybody and it's it is so nice to sit
shoulder to shoulder again with people
that you love people that are fully
strangers in the theater
and have that Collective feeling of fear
and joy and love and heartbreak and
surprise and I think we need that as
humans this is a everything I said about
what a lovely warm charcuterie boy when
this started
[Music]
[Applause]
you did it wonderful
there was one where I was like I'm out
of my body I'm out of my body and like
every time I tried to breathe in it had
like a vapor to it and it really made it
worse was that the bomb one I think that
probably started our spicy shark I think
that's where it starts and then it
doesn't stop after that yeah and they
each are like they're all terrible in
their own different ways and that's why
we love it and that's why we love them
I mean I I get it and I don't get it
right right it's just fun though in a in
a like when you break your legs
[Laughter]
okay
hey what's going on hot ones fans this
is Sean Evans and if you've ever watched
hot ones and wondered to yourself how
hot are those sauces really I can get
through that with no water or milk well
now is the time to put your money where
your mouth is the hot ones season 21
lineup is now available in its entirety
at heatness.com heatness.com that's
heatness.com to get your hands on the
season 21 hot Ones hot sauce lineup milk
not included be careful around the eyes
and get them while they're hot
mother